say we have a decimal fraction like 12
over 20 what percentage is this what if
I tell you to convert this to percent
form all you really need to do is
multiply the decimal fraction by 100 so
we have 12 over 20 multiplied by 120
times 5 is 112 times 5 is 60 yes 60
percent if we have a decimal fraction we
just need to multiply it with 100 to
convert it into percent terms but why is
this always true
what's the logic look at this example
there are 12 parts out of 20 by asking
us to find the percent we are actually
asked how many parts out of 100 it will
be this multiplied by this over this 12
times 100 over 20 it's a simple case of
proportion does this always work let's
erase this and look at a couple of
examples 8 by 25 to convert it into
percent terms we multiply 8 by 25 with
125 times 4 is 100 and 8 times 4 is 32 8
by 25 is 32 percent
here's another 175 by 150 how do you
convert it to percent terms you multiply
it by 100
correct wait look carefully you don't
really need to do this is actually 1 by
2 or 1/2 and 1/2 is 50%
you